to india now which seems to be past the
peak of its second coronavirus wave
but the country is now fighting another
crisis those recovering from covet 19
seem to be more vulnerable to a
dangerous fungal infection
the black fungus as it's called it's a
deadly but once rare disease
has now been declared an epidemic in
several indian states
dw correspondent namisha jaiswal sent us
this report from the capital
delhi iron has spent the last two months
in and out of hospitals
when her parents caught the coronavirus
during the worst of india's second wave
she stayed up nights desperately looking
for oxygen cylinders and hospital
beds she had to travel some 300
kilometers to jaipur
just to find her mother an icu bed where
she spent
three weeks a few days after returning
home
her mother was hospitalized again this
time
because of mucor mycosis commonly known
as the black fungus
iron describes wards overrun with
patients with eyes swollen shut
faces disfigured by life-saving
surgeries made necessary to stop the
spread of the fungus
a black fungus patient in the same room
as her mother bled to death before her
eyes
iron says she cannot allow herself the
time to stop and process this trauma
and i can't effort to even
have the luxury to lament because i have
to keep going i have to do whatever it
takes to keep going i can't afford to
think
i can't afford to sympathize i can't
afford to behave like a victim
right now because i have to constantly
act the black fungus has been declared
an epidemic in delhi
and several other states in india it is
not a new disease
but it occurred so rarely that
pharmacies did not stop much of the drug
used to treat it
we used to receive around two three
requests for the injections
for this amphotericism b a week but
right now
the demand went so high that it crossed
more than 30. patients
a day and there were many looking for it
unless patients receive an injection
regularly for several weeks
the fungus can spread rapidly each vial
costs 80 euros
as the demand has surged the black
market price has quadrupled
as prices for the antifungal drug
skyrocketed the government cut off sales
at pharmacies like these
now manufacturers and imports are
supposed to be supplied directly
to hospitals but these supplies will be
crucial
as even a single missed dose can be
devastating
the mold that causes the black fungus is
common in the environment
but can also be found in unclean
ventilators or oxygen cylinders
these were used heavily during india's
second wave
dr ramil tikku calls these opportunistic
infections
they swoop in when your immunity is
compromised
in this case by the corona virus and the
overuse of steroids used in its
treatment
any missteps in treating the black
fungus can be fatal
mucour mycosis has a high mortality rate
especially with patients who
don't get diagnosed early enough so it
has more than 50
mortality most of the time involved
surgery which can be disfiguring
especially with the common variety that
we see rhinoceros mucour where
you have to remove the dead tissue from
the face now
a rise in other fungal infections that
prey on weakened immune systems
is also being reported india's
coronavirus cases may be falling
but the deadly second wave has left
thousands vulnerable to many more
infections
and let's get more now we are joined by
professor for professor
oliver cornelli he is a infectious
disease specialist from the university
of cologne
thank you so much for joining us to
share your expertise and i'd like to
begin by asking you because we've heard
that
india has a shortage of supplies of
medicine to treat these fungal
infections what is the
prospect of treatment without the drugs
without the drugs you would be left just
with surgery
which is of course not a good option you
need usually to combine bones
okay um so i mean that that's a pretty
dire
scenario that you're outlining there um
just walk us through because we've we've
heard about the rising cases in india
how about elsewhere in the world are you
also seeing
other cases
well everywhere in the world we do see
cases
uh connected to covet 19 however
it is very small numbers so i'm aware
for example at the moment
in germany of less than five cases
how high is the risk that these types of
infections spread
they usually go or they do not spread
from patient to patient
so the mechanism is that you inhale the
fungus and the fungus usually
lives in soil or in decaying matter
and you inhale it and then it seeds
the mucous membranes where it starts
growing and invading
and causing disease but you don't pass
it on to somebody else
so you know if you're somebody you're
sitting in you know
another country in the world should we
be concerned about this
well we need to keep of course alert
and we should do the proper diagnostics
if you diagnose it early that's key to
treatment
and i guess that is what's being done in
most parts of the world
okay oliver cornery infectious disease
specialist from the university of
cologne
thank you so much for joining us thank
you
you